right whoo man
this is pretty cool
it is
um
[Applause]
it's been probably one of the most
unforgettable weeks that I've had
uh just you know traveling around the
world you know promoting this movie you
know Creed Three comes out
it's Friday same Shameless plug
and um
and you know doing something I always
wanted to do is is uh is direct you know
and and and promote the old school way
you know with family and friends and and
um and get this message out to the world
but I'm I'm I'm extremely humble
and grateful to be here
um I want to thank the committee you
know for this incredible honor
to be amongst artists that receive this
you know this designer previously you
know Sidney Poitier Cicely Tyson Sam
Cook I know it's not a small achievement
and it's not lost on me on how special
this moment is and what this represents
to our community so from the bottom of
my heart I want to say thank you
um
I really did not want to read off a
piece of paper at all but
it's a lot of things I want to I want to
kind of get to a little bit of here
I want to thank everybody for being here
today and taking time out of your busy
lives and schedule just to celebrate
this moment with me I know how important
time is and uh and I appreciate you guys
being here with me it means a lot
uh
the love and the energy that you guys
send my way when I'm out doing what I
got to do promote and travel and work
and I feel all of it and I appreciate it
sincerely you know I may not be able to
get back to everybody all the time you
know in a timely manner but just trust
me it sits for me and everything that I
do I'm always thinking about it you know
so thank you guys
I also want to thank the people who are
the reason why I'm standing up here
today
I'm gonna start out with my crew you
know you know it may just be my name on
that plaque but trust me you know I
would not be here without the people who
have supported me on my journey
throughout the years the people that
ride through me right ride with me
through thick and thin
the people that believed in me before my
name was on you know Hollywood Walk of
Fame
you know feel
Greg Patrick you know Brooke Lindsay
drove Maggie Leo
Chad Bobby Renee Natalie Sterling you
know what I'm saying that was my core
I'm not I can't name everybody
but those are those those are the ones
that really rock with me through and
through
my amazing friends
you know I don't know where I would be
without you guys seriously so thank you
most importantly I want to thank my
family
you know my mom
you know my dad
my brother Khalid my sister Jamila my
brother-in-law Jamila and Reggie
of course
the newest edition Linux
it's my guy right there yeah give him
back his phone
uh and the little one that's on the way
growing up in Newark New Jersey the idea
of receiving an honor like this was like
a dream
but I've always been a dream chaser you
know never been afraid of hard work
that fire inside of me like led to
opportunities on All My Children the
wire Friday Night Lights
then of course have an opportunity to
work opposite the remarkable Talent of
Chadwick Bozeman and black panther and
ultimately that led to this directing
directed my first feature
three three
I want to say thank you to my brother
Jonathan Mages for joining joining me on
this Creed Journey
supporting me here today
get me all
teary eyed and I don't want to be
um it was a true honor to watch to watch
you and your Genius every day from
behind the camera
in a way that you made it harder for me
to hop in front of the camera and slack
you in the face every once in a while
your spirit in your soul is something I
connected with from day one
um
and when we sat down at dinner we
decided to be friends I took that
seriously
um you've become one of my brothers you
know uh
and um outside of all the industry stuff
and the film television and the politics
and all that stuff like that you can
call on me whenever you need me and I'll
be there for you
solid yeah
cheat creep sorry guys
Creed challenged me in ways I never
thought was possible
it changed my entire perspective on what
we can do in this town
and working on a film I was reminded of
how hard it is to make anything at all
let alone something great
that's not me that's what Rotten
Tomatoes said that's that's that's that
wasn't me
the boundaries of what can be done and
really bring a story to life in a way
that your mind and heart envisions it
and I'll tell you I'll tell you one
thing it gave me an even deeper
appreciation for this man
that I call my brother Ryan coogler
pairing up with Kooks changed my entire
life from trusting me to embody Oscar
Grant story and Fruitville Station back
in 2013.
which brought two young black hopeful
artists to a standing ovation at Cam's
Film Festival
to making up to the making of Black
Panther and creation of Eric killmonger
one of the realest most badass
characters in the MCU
to finally making me Adonis Creed
coog has always been in my corner
he's always been something to me
he's always seen something in me and
pushed me to dream bigger of myself
so to say I appreciate you Ryan
would be an understatement my gratitude
to you for believing in me and for
empowering me with this church with this
third chapter of creed is never ending
before I get out of here I just want to
say thank you for everything to
everybody that's been that's here
um
thank you
the people that really know me I often
say man I don't deserve this you know
it fiend it seems very um I don't know
when you're constantly on on a journey I
very rarely stop and like smell the
roses and like taking moments I'm always
moving on to the next thing
uh this fleeing feeling of time slipping
away from you
and
you know for the first time in a really
long time
I I'm taking this moment in you know uh
people that I don't know strangers
people that know me very well uh see me
along the way you know
I'm taking this in so
thank you
[Applause]